they average 62 million queries per day
I have no idea I mean what do you think
Google's queries per day probably like
like 5 million okay let's start with go
okay I've I was on the James Altucher
podcast James was here with us a few
weeks ago James is like a like a dork
nerdy guy I say this would love I like
him a lot he's like a nerdy guy
libertarian guy libertarian audience and
I can't decide if this whole privacy
stuff that we're talking about so hey
calm female service launched a few days
ago a few weeks ago a week ago yeah its
premise is like we're gonna one of its
many promises is its on privacy okay and
so I'm really into this privacy thing
the founder of Pandora told me that he
is seeing his customers who are Middle
American people actually care about
privacy and when I was on my trip I saw
DuckDuckGo billboards everywhere for
those who don't know duck taco it's a
google competitor it's a search engine
and they it's all based on they don't
track you which like [__] ruins the
business model have no idea how they
make money but no no it doesn't so their
thing was like it's not no ads so they
still do search ads but they're like
look when you search for you said you're
gonna go buy a new car when you go
search for you know Mercedes versus BMW
or whatever you're gonna search for
they'll serve you an ad they just don't
need to know that you're sampar that you
live in this place that you have life
you know they don't need the personal
data for the ads to still be effective
because search is high intent they know
what you're looking for so they can
serve you of relevant ad and their
insight was the slight drop off you get
by not personalizing is not so bad if
that can become your value proposition
that hey we're not using personal
information to serve these ads okay so I
just sent you their traffic go to
DuckDuckGo comm slash traffic so here's
my question to you first of all we're
looking at a hockey stick we're looking
at anomalous and 10 2010 they're at you
know this is this is queries per day or
this is average yeah so they average 62
million queries per day I have no idea I
mean what do you think Google's queries
per day probably like like five billion
I mean a braid see if you can find let's
see if you can find Google's careers
today so we can put this so 3.5 billion
off ok ok yes go ahead
Google or duck duck goes that fifty
fifty sixty million a day so there I
don't even know what's that like three
percent the size anyway DuckDuckGo what
do you think about that I I personally
love this and what I want to know from
you is do you like duck oh and do you
also think this privacy thing like
building products were the main feature
or values in like or like the main thing
the brain stands for is privacy do you
think that's gonna be it
I think it's a hit I used to think the
opposite I used to be of the camp that
was like look people don't give a [__]
like if you just say yeah sure in theory
people want privacy if you offer no
privacy or privacy but when it comes
down to products they're like oh this is
a free good thing and I have to give up
all my data alright here you go
and so I used to think that people in
practice who are willing to easily trade
privacy and I think that's still true on
the whole but if you said yes where is
the pendulum swinging and so I think the
pendulum is swinging more towards people
caring about privacy because every these
things stack up right so as you you know
the more paranoid you get the less lack
of trust you have in the system and of
the of the big companies it doesn't
matter you don't have to know which one
is the straw that breaks the camel's
back maybe it's the fake new stuff on
Facebook maybe it's when your
information gets breached for the 35th
time and you get an email saying hey
sorry your personal if I might have been
leaked like you don't know where it is
but these things just keep happening and
to the point where I believe people care
more than they did before and they'll
continue to care more that's that's
number one number two you have to do it
on a global product like a product
everybody uses cuz it's still a niche
audience alright like you said Google is
about 50 times the search query size
then in DuckDuckGo up so like 50 to 1
and so you need a product that's used by
pretty much everybody for that those
ones to add up and be a big enough
market for you so I wouldn't do it on
some niche products like oh you do you
know some niche mailing you know
hmm MailChimp software thing cool I'm
gonna make a privacy focus version it's
like no that's that's a nisha of a niche
well if it's about ego stream it works
like hey calm
I caught hey calm global write emails
everybody yes it is global but like you
don't need that many users to build a
billion-dollar company totally what I'm
- that's was saying though you need but
you're only gonna get the sort of 2%
let's say that value privacy enough to
make a change and so you know like
superhuman did the same thing email such
a huge market cool we'll go get the 1%
2% who are willing to pay 30 bucks a
month for a free instead of free email I
think this is anything happening here
I pray you how old are you 27 you're a
little old for this question the zoom
ray just five years ago no it's a
generational thing I want to know do the
22 year olds give a [__] about this
because the way that the Zoomers the way
that they live and think is really [__]
about getting coronaviruses the privacy
of their data they don't care about
their body they're a pretty
conscientious group of people I think I
don't know I would I want to know how
they think
but that was my question okay so here's
another private here's another
opportunity for privacy that I'm
interested in do you know that when you
go to Safeway so in California we have
Safeway in the South you've got Kroger
and the other South you've got Publix
what else is there
Albertsons Albertsons okay so when you
go to your grocery store like your major
grocery store you enter in your phone
number to get a discount right what they
do with that is they understand your
buying behavior and they'll show you
they'll send you stuff in the mail or
they will just learn about inventory
whatever and this is incredibly
effective so effective at there's a
famous story about a woman being a
sixteen year old get a woman getting
mailed stuff to her dad's home saying
like baby supplies and the dad was like
right my daughter 16 she's not pregnant
what he talked about
turns out she was pregnant and they knew
it because in your party yeah yeah month
you know what to buy
anyway when you go and buy that ship did
you know that you can submit like a
request and they'll send you all of your
do-not-track requests well that you
could do it do not track and they can
send you everything you've ever bought
oh that's pretty cool okay
alike so what what would you do with
that data yeah I think that's just an
interesting thing you could do in
general like a mint calm style I think
you could say hey what's your phone
number okay then you go request it on
behalf of the customer and you give them
cool visualizations about their spending
patterns over time and other products
they might like but I don't what do you
what I want to do with that data if I
was the company or if I was myself what
do you think if you're trying to build a
business I would go figure out other
areas where this sort of like linking
and tracking will work and so so a lot
of people have already done this right
like the ad market it's kind of like
porn where porn innovates first okay a
close second or third might be the ad
market so you know FERC on who was kind
of my co-founder CTO of my previous
company his previous company was an ad
tech company and they one of the
versions of their app that they made so
the companies called app lovin and so
initially the premise was what apps are
your friends loving we will recommend
those apps to you and so it was like if
I know what apps you have and I know
that you're my friend cuz you're in my
address book then it can tell me that
sampar loves this app I thought it was a
play on McLovin
no it was I don't know maybe that was a
side benefit cuz every love super bad
but won it but then all kinds of little
edge cases started [__] them up so
they would you know record they would
tell me that you love Grindr
right like so so first it's like not
everybody's app behavior they want to be
transparent to their friends or their
contacts and I think there was one
really horrible case where this so then
they switched us trying to do this for
app installs so they're like okay if I'm
playing a game and it's awesome I'm
sorry forget about it's awesome I'm
playing a game and they want you to
download that game because they get paid
nine bucks if you download the game they
would show my face from your address
book as hey Shaun's playing candy crush
right now tap here to play candy crush
to and that was like a super effective
ad unit like there were like printing
money and I think something really bad
happened where like the CEO of Expedia
or something like that got an ad that
like his deceased wife was playing this
game or something like that like someone
from his address book who had this app
was shown to him and he's like what the
hell is this and so he got back to them
and they had
turn it off and they would they did a
similar experiment around
location-tracking like have a life 360
thing so yeah you're really careful with
these like data
oh let's use data to give you
information about either yourself or
others you can get the situation like
the dad who finds out a 16 year olds
pregnant yeah I long story short privacy
okay I have a privacy idea for you I
love a privacy idea for you so I just
because I've become like I like the
older I've gotten I've gotten like more
libertarian and like [__] the government
like mentality well there's two things
are happening there's people who bring
on a libertarian which is like eff the
government and if the man in general and
then there's people are becoming more
nationalistic which is like it's us
first them and us first them mean sort
of keep them out and raise us up and I
think in both cases you see this sort of
like retreat in both cases it's sort of
it's not like a shelter in place
physically but it's a shelter in place
sort of psychologically behaviorally
where you reduce your like openness and
your spread you know in your behaviors
and your data in another way so I think
people in general when times get a
little crazy people there's a flight to
safety and I see I think you see this
with investing I think you see this with
the way people act to behave so I think
that more people do it when they're when
times get turbulent now a privacy
focused idea that I had the other day so
moved into this new house need to get
internet set up oh [__]
gotta play the Comcast game Comcast
comes over and of course you know Wi-Fi
doesn't really work great in my house so
I was like okay I need to invest in good
Wi-Fi because not having good Wi-Fi is
like not having water to drink and so
I'm like looking for these like euro
these kind of mesh networks that you use
in your house I just thought one give
you more coverage so I just bought euro
but I was talking to FERC on and I was
like I think euro sucks well I hope it
doesn't sock cuz I just bought it but
but the idea that I was thinking about
was you know how when you what typically
happens you have your Wi-Fi router and
then on your laptop you'll have like a
VPN so a lot of people have VPNs VPNs
are more and more popular some people
have it for work some people have it to
hide their traffic as they go bootleg
movies on the internet and they don't
want it to be sort of traced to them
and so VPNs are kind of complicated like
to set up like you got to download one
you don't know if it's malware you're
setting it up average person doesn't
know what the hell VPN is I was asking
done a ton of research on this market
well the idea was actually why don't you
build VPN into the router so you never
need to download anything it's just VPN
by default and it'll thing into the
hardware itself and so you actually the
the value prop of the router is this is
secure internet and and so there so he
so forgot of course like you know
there's people doing this and so I can't
say I'm the first to have this idea but
he was telling me about a couple
companies to check out if you're
interested in this so next DNS is one of
them ubiquity is another one and so he
was showing me a few of these that today
are still kind of like you kind of need
to be a developer to know about these or
be like know how to configure them to
set them up and so I think if somebody
takes the euro level of simplicity and
design but they make the value prop hey
your your internet search traffic your
whatever you're doing on the Internet is
private if you buy this box instead of
that box I think hard thing behind that
the hard thing about these comfort of
all the VPN businesses I did a wrote
about them because I think that it's
gonna explode and they already are
exploding but a lot of them are based in
Panama because of the privacy laws there
and a lot of them are notoriously scammy
and weird they're also ridiculously
profitable like I talked to the one guy
he had one it made twin a million
dollars a year in revenue and like a
hundred million in profit like right
stupid but euro do you remember you know
euro got bought by Google I think Amazon
I think Amazon it like got acquired for
nothing these companies are so hard to
make money because it costs so much
money right yeah I think hardware is
hard everybody knows that
like ring doorbell you know it gets a
billion dollar outcome but like I don't
think it was like ultra profitable at
the time I think it was strategic the
reason it got bought but the reason I
think Wi-Fi router is interesting
because Wi-Fi is like email it's like
Google search it's a thing that
everybody has every every physical place
has a router and so though 2% of that
market that cares about privacy
I think it's still a big market and I
think I don't I don't believe that it's
so hard to make money because again you
like with this Comcast box that I have
here I gotta pay these guys 14 bucks a
month just for this router to sit here
it's no way this router is worth more
than like 50 dollars but they're gonna
make money on me you know they'll break
even in five months and they know I'm
never gonna like get rid of my router
and so so yeah I think that there's
something interesting there yeah also
[__] those guys
[Music]